Hey there, I’m Mike Rugnetta and this is
Crashcourse Mythology and today we’re going
to start looking at pantheons.
Pantheons are families of gods, and those
families are complicated.
Really complicated.
A whole tangle of grandparents and parents
and uncles and aunts and nieces and nephews
and a couple of children of mortal women who
were raped and a pretty staggering amount
of violence and incest to just round everything
off.
They have amazing feasts, but honestly, can
you imagine Thanksgiving with these people?
I mean Thoth, you had a mistress and a wife
and you somehow gave birth to yourself.
How is that not awkward?
INTRO
The pantheons we are going to examine are
families of deities from cultures that are
usually considered polytheistic, meaning that
they worshipped more than one god.
In most mythological traditions, the gods
are seen as immortal, and according to David
Leeming, “they are personified projections
of the human mythmaker’s dreams of overcoming
the inevitable effects of the physical laws
that require death and disintegration.”
Yeah.
We went dark pretty quick.
In creation stories and other myths, gods
represent the creative force that brings and
sustains life.
In many myths, gods are “personifications
of aspects of nature and of human nature – the
sun, the winds, impatience, love.”
Pantheons, David Leeming argues, help us to
explain how and why the world we know came
into being, and can tell us a lot about a
culture.
Leeming writes:
“All pantheons are ontological and teleological;
that is they are metaphors for the human attempt
to make sense of existence itself and to assign
ultimate cause.
To “read” a pantheon is to read a culture’s
sense of itself and of the nature of the cosmos.”
But can pantheons explain the naked mole rat?
Let’s find out together.
If you thought that I was going to start with
the Greeks, ha!
Gotcha!
High five Thoth.
But we’re not starting with Egypt either.
Sorry.
We’re going to start with one of the oldest
pantheons we have records for, the family
of Gods from ancient Sumer in Mesopotamia.
Sumer’s pantheon represents the most important
natural forces in the lives of Ancient Mesopotamians,
and there are a lot of deities here, so strap
in.
Try to pay attention to everyone’s responsibilities,
and note what kinds of things don’t have
gods.
All right.
Here we go.
The first pair of deities are the earth goddess,
Ki, and the sky god, called An.
An mates with Ki, AND Nammu, goddess of primal
waters.
An and Nammu’s children are Enki, the trickster
god, and his sister, Ningikuga the goddess
of the reeds.
An and Ki, the more significant duo, begat
Ninlil, the air goddess, and Enlil the air
god.
Ninlil and Enlil give birth to Nanna, the
Moon God.
Enki and his sister Ningikuga create Ningal,
the Moon Goddess.
Ningal and Nanna then have three children.
Utu, the sun god, Inanna, the “Great Goddess
of Heaven and Earth”, and Ereshkigal, the
Queen of the Underworld.
Ereshkigal’s “husband” is Gugalanna,
the Bull of Heaven.
And Inanna marries the Shepherd Dumuzi.
Dumuzi, it turns out, was the son of Enki,
the trickster god, and his consort, the sheep
goddess Sirtur.
It may be worth nothing that yes: a sheep
goddess DID give birth to a shepherd.
So that is the basic pantheon of Sumer, but
what does all this tell us about Mesopotamia?
First it suggests that, at least in terms
of their myths, natural phenomena--like the
earth and sky--take precedence over human
actions and emotions--like love.
I mean, only two of the original Mesopotamian
gods, Enki the trickster and Inanna, also
the goddess of love, are described as ruling
over aspects of human nature.
And the sheep?
Well, we tend to think agriculture when we
talk about the Fertile Crescent, but the fact
that their pantheon features Sheep and a Bull
rather than a harvest deity might recall an
earlier life as herders.
Or perhaps the Bull is symbolic not only of
masculinity but also of farming.
This is the fun part of pantheons specifically
and mythology generally; you can read them
in many ways.
No, Thoth that’s not a joke about hieroglyphics.
And this leads us to our next, significantly
more complex family of gods, the Egyptian
pantheon.
Right off the bat I’m going to say that
the Egyptian pantheon is even more confusing
than your average confusing pantheon.
But surprise, surprise, it’s also just as
incestuous.
First off: There is no standard version of
the Egyptian pantheon.
the myth changes depending upon who is writing
it.
And where.
And when.
For example, in the story of Isis and Osiris,
our most complete source isn’t even Egyptian,
it’s the Greek biographer Plutarch, who
wrote in the first and second centuries CE,
well after Egypt had become Hellenized, and
then Romanized.
In his version of the Isis and Osiris myths,
he gives Egyptian gods Greek names.
For example, he refers to Thoth as Hermes,
he does still give you credit for inventing
darts, though, so.
There are also different versions of the pantheon
depending on where you are in Egypt.
For the most part we’ll be sticking with
the group of gods worshipped at the city of
Heliopolis and headed by Atum or Ra, but we’ll
give a nod to the fact that in Thebes the
pantheon was led by Amun.
And we can’t forget the attempted monotheism
of Akhenaton.
That was classic.
But just to make this even trickier, a lot
of the Egyptian sources we have for myths
are fragmentary and spread out over thousands
of years.
So, for simplicity, we’re going to settle
on the Nine-God pantheon that forms the core
of Egyptian religious belief, and it … doesn’t
include Thoth.
Sorry, buddy.
Anyway, the Ennead, or Nine Gods, was in place
in Heliopolis by 2700 BCE and is the one found
in the Pyramid Texts, which might be the oldest
surviving set of religious texts in the world.
At the top of this pantheon is Atum, aka Re
aka Ra, aka Khepri aka Amun or sometimes Amun-Ra,
depending on where in Egypt you are.
This is why we’re simplifying!
Atum is the great eye of the heavens and of
creation.
He was the spitter in our Egyptian creation
story.
So Atum’s creative cough creates Shu, the
life spirit, and Tefnut, the world order or
cosmos.
This brother and sister pair mate, and give
birth to Geb and Nut.
Geb is the spirit of life and Nut is an Egyptian
Great Mother goddess.
The two are separated by their father, Shu,
and Geb becomes Earth while Nut becomes the
sky and the stars, which is a neat reversal
of the whole earth mother sky father thing.
Like their parents, brother and sister Geb
and Nut become the mother and father of the
rest of the gods in this pantheon.
Their children, Osiris and Isis are probably
the best known Egyptian gods, other than hawk-headed
Ra.
Osiris, god of the underworld and grain, kind
of like a Demeter/Hades combo, was probably
the most popular of the Egyptian gods-because
who doesn’t like food and death?
He dies and is revived, which happens more
than you’d expect, in myth.
Actually, maybe just as much as you’d expect
in myth.
Isis is a goddess of the earth and the moon,
and is married to Osiris.
The mystery cult of Isis was popular well
beyond Egypt, into Roman times.
And if you’re not sure what a mystery cult,
guess what, that’s the point.
The second son and third child from the Geb-Nut
pairing is Seth.
Seth is a god of evil and darkness and is
the nemesis of Isis and Osiris.
He is married to his sister, Nephthys, a goddess
of death and dusk, because you know, if you’re
going to be married for all eternity, it’s
nice to share interests.
And the final piece of this puzzle is young
Horus, not to be confused with old Horus,
or the guy from WarHammer.
He was conceived miraculously by Isis and
Osiris after the latter’s death, and he
has aspects of a sun god.
He’s a light that defeats Seth’s darkness.
Most important though, Horus, who is often
depicted with the head of a falcon (not a
hawk, not an ibis) is the spiritual force
behind the pharaohs.
I know you’re wondering when we’re going
to talk about Anubis, Bastet, and Sekhmet,
but remember, for the sake of comparative
simplicity, we’re sticking by this nine-god
pantheon.
So what conclusions can we draw from the basic
pantheon?
There are multiple versions of sun gods and
with Ra representing both the sun and creation,
and Horus representing both the sun and kingship,
we can infer that the sun was important to
the Egyptians, probably as much for its eternal
cycle of death and rebirth as for its providing
life-giving energy.
Ancient Egyptian culture is commonly said
to focus on death, and that’s not wrong,
although death to the Egyptians probably didn’t
hold the same terror that it does for many
in the modern world.
I think the most distinct example of this
necro-centric ideal is the pyramids, and the
mummified corpses and jars full of organs
found within them, but also this week’s
featured myth, the story of Isis and Osiris.
Take it away, Thoughtbubble.
Osiris was much beloved by the people of Egypt;
he showed them how to cultivate grain, gave
them laws, and taught them to honor the gods.
His brother, Seth, was envious, but wouldn’t
try anything while Osiris was away teaching
civilization to the world.
But when Osiris returned, Seth and seventy-two
accomplices had a plan.
A plan involving...furniture.
They had secretly measured Osiris’s body
and built a beautiful chest to his exact dimensions.
At a party celebrating Osiris’s return,
Seth suggested that whoever fit in the chest
would receive it as a gift.
Osiris gave it a shot, and when he lay down
in the box, the conspirators nailed it shut
and sealed it with lead.
They threw it in the river and, it floated
out to sea.
Isis, Osiris’s wife, went looking for
her husband, and found the chest near the
land of Byblos, where a great tree had grown
up around it, encasing the coffin in its trunk.
She cut away the wood around the coffin and
lay upon it, wailing with such grief and power
that the king’s younger sons died of fear.
Isis soon left the chest to visit Horus, and
Seth found the coffin while boar hunting.
He cut up Osiris’s body into 14 pieces,
and scattered them far and wide.
Isis, discovering what Seth had done, set
out to search for the pieces.
She found thirteen of them, but not what Izanami
might have described as “his excess.”
She buried the pieces where she found them,
which is why there are so many graves for
Osiris in Egypt.
Seth couldn’t find the true grave of Osiris,
and Osiris would be worshipped throughout
Egypt.
Win/Win.
Except for, the fact that he was dead.
Or WAS HE?
Thanks, Thoughtbubble.
This is one version of the story, but in another
version, upon finding the body of Osiris,
Isis and her sister Nephthys wept such a loud
lamentation that Ra the sun god took pity
on them and sent down Jackal-headed Anubis
to help Isis and Nephthys.
The two sisters, with the help of Anubis,
Thoth and Horus pieced Osiris back together
and wrapped him in linen bandages and performed
the funeral rites.
Isis flapped her wings over the body and Osiris
revived.
From then on he became the king of the dead,
ruling in the underworld.
So this myth illustrates some central facets
of Egyptian culture.
One is the idea of Osiris as king and god,
much like the pharaohs.
Another is the role of mummification in Egyptian
life., Or death., or well, actually: both.
The binding of Osiris and his revival is a
promise to Egyptians of eternal life.
According to David Leeming, Egyptians, “believed
that every man would live eternal in the other
world if only his surviving friends did for
his body what the gods had done for the body
of Osiris; … as Osiris died and rose again
from the dead, so all men hoped to rise like
him…”
This myth also suggests that in Egypt, the
pantheon is somewhat fluid, with gods performing
numerous roles.
Osiris goes from being the father of civilization
to the ruler of the underworld, a role that
in later Egyptian mythology will be taken
over by Anubis, while Seth is the source of
evil and trouble, the jealous younger brother
always trying -- and sometimes succeeding
– to take the place of his older brother.
We have a tendency to view pantheons as explanations
of natural phenomena that correspond between
particular gods and particular aspects of
nature, like the sun’s rising and setting.
But often the gods resist falling into such
restrictive roles.
And as myths like Isis and Osiris show, it’s
the particular stories that matter to people,
as much as if not more than who is the goddess
of what and why.
Just ask Saga, Norse goddess of storytelling. We're going to meet her really soon.
But until then.  Thanks for watching. We'll see you next week.